Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¿Qué podrían tener los pulpos
en común con nosotros?
Después de todo, no tienen
pulmones ni espinas dorsales.
Pero sí pueden resolver acertijos,
aprender de la observación,
e incluso usar herramientas,
como otros animales que conocemos.
Y lo que hace tan increíble
a la inteligencia de los pulpos
es que viene de una estructura biológica
totalmente diferente de la nuestra.
Las cerca de 200 especies de pulpos
son moluscos pertenecientes
a los cefalópodos,
en griego, cabeza-pies.
Esas cabezas contienen cerebros
impresionantemente grandes,
con una proporción cerebro-cuerpo
similar a otros animales inteligentes,
y un sistema nervioso complejo con
tantas neuronas como tiene el perro.
Pero en vez de estar
centralizadas en el cerebro,
estos 500 millones de neuronas están
en una red de ganglios interconectados
organizados en 3 estructuras básicas.
El cerebro central solo contiene
un 10 % de las neuronas,
mientras que los 2 grandes
lóbulos ópticos contienen un 30 %.
El otro 60 % está en los tentáculos,
que para los humanos sería
como tener brazos con cerebros.
Ahí es donde la cosa
se pone más interesante.
Los vertebrados tenemos esqueletos
rígidos para sostener el cuerpo,
con articulaciones que
nos permiten movernos.
Pero no podemos hacer
cualquier movimiento.
No podemos doblar la rodilla
hacia adelante,
ni flexionar el antebrazo
por el medio, por ejemplo.
Los cefalópodos, por otro lado,
no tienen huesos en absoluto,
y pueden flexionar sus extremidades
en cualquier lugar y dirección.
Por eso sus tentáculos adoptan
formas casi ilimitadas,
algo a lo que no estamos acostumbrados.
Piensa en tareas simples
como tomar y comer una manzana.
El cerebro humano tiene
un mapa neurológico del cuerpo.
Cuando ves la manzana,
el centro motor de tu cerebro
activa los músculos apropiados,
permitiéndote alcanzarla con tu brazo,
tomarla en tu mano,
flexionar el codo
y llevarla a la boca.
Para un pulpo, el proceso
es bastante diferente.
En vez de tener un mapa del cuerpo,
el cerebro del cefalópodo tiene
una biblioteca de comportamiento.
Así que cuando un pulpo ve comida,
su cerebro no activa una parte
específica del cuerpo,
sino más bien una respuesta
conductual para agarrar.
Conforme la señal viaja por la red,
las neuronas del brazo toman el mensaje
y se lanzan a la acción
para comandar el movimiento.
Ni bien el brazo toca la comida,
una onda de activación muscular
viaja por el brazo hasta su base,
al tiempo que el brazo devuelve otra
onda desde la base hasta la punta.
Las señales se encuentran a medio camino
entre el alimento y la base del brazo,
y ese es el punto a flexionar.
Eso significa que cada uno
de los 8 brazos del pulpo,
en esencia, puede pensar por sí mismo.
Esto les da una flexibilidad
y creatividad increíbles
para enfrentar nuevas
situaciones o problemas,
sea abrir una botella
para alcanzar el alimento,
escapar de un laberinto,
moverse en un nuevo entorno,
cambiar la textura y el color de la
piel para mimetizarse con el paisaje,
o incluso imitar a otras criaturas
para ahuyentar a los enemigos.
Los cefalópodos pueden haber
evolucionado cerebros complejos
mucho antes que nuestros
parientes vertebrados.
Y la inteligencia de los pulpos
no es útil solo para los pulpos.
Sus sistemas nerviosos radicalmente
diferentes y su pensamiento autónomo
han inspirado nueva investigación
en el desarrollo de robots flexibles
hechos de materiales blandos.
Y estudiar cómo puede surgir inteligencia
por un camino evolutivo tan divergente
puede ayudarnos a entender más la
inteligencia y la conciencia en general.
Quién sabe qué otras formas
de vida inteligente son posibles,
o cómo procesan el mundo circundante.